if you were transported into an
alternate reality full of deadly Killers
what would you do masked murderers are
hunting you down and the consequences
for being caught is a gruesome death I'm
here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
masked killers in high-rise Invasion
this little girl is about to realize
that Tokyo has become a violent death
trap schoolgirl Yuri here calls up her
mum and dad and they don't answer the
girl has suddenly been transported to an
alternate world and she's now stuck on
this high-rise building with no Escape
her brother picks up the phone and
informs her that this place is not an
illusion he's trapped in this world as
well trying to get down from these
high-rise buildings but all the
elevators and stairs are blocked and all
the rooftops are connected with these
strange wooden bridges suddenly Yuri
watches as a masked person chases this
innocent lady around another high-rise
her brother reveals that these masks on
only purpose is to make them Panic
mentally pushing them off the building
her brother directs her vision to the
tallest building in the area but that's
when this masked killer swings at the
girl she tries to crawl away getting her
phone broken in the process because
she's a dumb dumb and she let go of her
phone Yuri gets up and runs over to the
wooden bridge and realizes that it's
extremely unstable the masked killer
follows her as she Sprints across the
building suddenly a cop kills the man
and looks over the edge to see where
he's landed but his subordinate pushes
him over and tells Yuri to sit still
suddenly this sniper brutally shoots the
man Yuri takes her chance to Run for
Cover she hides behind the wall as the
sniper Mass here continues firing that's
when Yuri notices the policeman is still
alive he tries crawling to safety but is
quickly shot dead the school girl drags
his body behind cover and searches
through his clothes and stuff for any
useful equipment okay based on the
clothes we're wearing we've just been
transported from a breezy day at a
Japanese High School all the way to an
endless Maze of deadly high-rise
buildings now we don't have time to
think about where we came from Since the
situation has already become a [ __ ] show
that sniper over there just saved Our
Lives meaning that not all the people in
this world are out to kill which is
great if he hadn't fired off a second
shot at us bummer if I was Yuri I'd take
whatever equipment possible from this
douchebag of a policeman and use it to
our advantage survival situations are
always full of unexpected circumstances
and taking his bulletproof vest is a
very good way to ensure that we have a
bit of protection his gun will come in
handy as well but what should be obvious
enough or even the dumbest of the
dum-dums to figure out is that you
should look around the area we can
easily tell that this place isn't really
part of the real world our brother only
told us to treat it like the real world
not that it was the real world the two
policemen confirmed that there's other
normal people roaming around this
alternate reality but most importantly
we can deduce from our interaction with
the authorities that some of them are at
least still moral human beings our first
mission should be to find other humans
just like us and form a deadly anime
team just like I have with Alan dumb
we're like the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse but there's only three of us
Yuri burns the policeman's body
realizing that this new world she's in
is a terrifying dangerous place later
she spots on masks and mate staring her
down Yuri whips out her new gun watching
as the killer jumps a massive distance
to reach her the maid runs towards Yuri
and slashes her with a sight Yuri shoots
back quickly realizing that this killer
is seemingly immune to gunshots however
she doesn't want to fight Yuri pretends
to back off and jump off of the building
tricking the killer into a deadly
headshot she climbs back up to see that
the Killer is in fact human the lady
tells her that those who wear masks are
under some sort of Mind Control Yuri
walks closer but the mask insists that
she stays put or she'll be killed the
lady is currently undermined control and
tells her to never look in the back of a
mask or else be forced under to the
command of a strange entity she repeats
the words of a computer's shutdown
sequence and is forced to destroy
herself Yuri tells her to take the mask
off but the lady says her goodbyes
before falling off of the high rise Yuri
realizes that she just made her first
kill in this deadly world she freaks out
when suddenly a ghost of the policeman
climbs up on the railing he teases the
girl Vanishing before she can respond
now she knows that these mask Killers
aren't the Real Enemy whoever is giving
the commands are responsible for
everything later she finds a bag full of
food and a gun Yuri realizes that she
needs to figure out what the hell is
going on as she looks at the next
Sinister high-rise building she finally
decides to sack up and walk inside and
finds a woman with a bullet wound
through her head opening this note on
the body she reads that a helicopter
service is operating which can send them
back to their reality suddenly she peeks
around the corner to see this blonde
girl nisei readying her gun at a
defenseless man Yuri shoots the gun away
with freakish Hawkeye accuracy and then
begs the girl to talk it over but the
mystery girl kills her Target anyways
nearly decapitating the man you're a
pointing her gun towards the girl gets
ready to kill her now this causes the
girl to break down and cry causing the
both of them to suddenly decide that
they are not going to kill each other
for now but then they're interrupted by
this masked sniper and the schoolgirl
saves them both from certain death
hiding behind the wall the sniper
bounces his bullet off of the knife and
nearly manages to hit them nisei takes
her up the stairs and decides to set a
little trap for the man setting off this
grenade as it blows him off the building
leaving them safe for now Yuri thanks
the girl for helping out but notices a
familiar hat on the ground and spaces
out for a sec nisei then says that she's
taking the helicopter upstairs so Yuri
hands over her ID and tells nisei to
tell her parents where she's been they
hear the helicopter leaving and the
girls Rush upstairs to find that it's
already taken off they're stuck in this
world for a bit longer okay now that we
know a little bit more about what's
going on we we can make a plan to get
out of here once and for all time is of
the essence and if I had to guess
there's only so much food and water
accessible for us to last another few
days the longer we wait the more our
mental faculties will begin to
deteriorate not only that we know that
for some reason reaching the ground
level is an impossible task ignoring the
fact that we can't reach the ground at
all we now know that these buildings are
possible to enter it's hard to say how
well they've safeguarded doors and
entrances to block us from going down
but this is a very good news if I were
the girls I would try and find a way
down this building with whatever means
necessary we might even have to resort
finding a rope and rappelling down into
the lower floors but it's important to
remember that most of these buildings so
far have been Office Buildings most
Office Buildings are filled full of
snacks and water while this is an
alternate reality there could be nothing
on the lower floors to discourage us
from reaching the ground it's worth a
shot to try and up our supplies before
traveling any further one other piece of
information that is extremely handy is
knowing that we can leave the area
safely this is the key to our survival
and getting out of here as soon as
possible is going to be better than
waiting around to be killed by a masked
Japanese dude the next day she wakes up
inside the building to find that nisei
has disappeared the schoolgirl finds a
bag of provisions and some boots and
realizes that her new friend has ditched
her and the boots that she left happened
to be the same boots that the dead chick
wore that's when she finds a mask on the
Rope Bridge below and she rushes
downstairs to go confront him she makes
a way across and realizes that there's
multiple masked Killers Yuri watches as
one of the masks walks to this Gap in
the bridge and notices the man helping
his teammate out suddenly he cuts off
all of her fingers off and she falls
down into the abyss The Masks begin
pacing towards Yuri she raises her gun
to shoot the final bullet but it doesn't
work that's when she remembers that Rika
mentioned police guns were faulty Yuri
turns around and trips off of the bridge
they Corner the girl but nisei manages
to save her just in time Yuri fires off
a few shots and they take the wounded
Man's mask off to question him he tells
them that wearing the mask makes you
obey a there every command and taking it
off isn't possible suddenly the man
brutally dies later Yuri realizes that
her new teammate has a phone she calls
up her brother who tells her to gather
more recruits find the helicopter and
get out he mentions that he can find her
location but it's going to take some
time before he arrives that's when her
brother mentions that she'll need to do
something horrifying before he arrives
he mentions that she'll need to kill
nisei if she wants to stay safe because
no one can truly be trusted in this
world but Yuri says that she won't be
killing anyone and the brother decides
to stop his search for the girl instead
He suggests they both wait in different
high-rises to catch the helicopter when
it lands meanwhile her brother Rika is
busy beating the [ __ ] out of these
masked Killers he's determined to take
them all out and won't stop until his
mission is accomplished he's found by
his two buddies who are glad to see him
safe and they head off when suddenly a
massive Cannonball shoots into the wall
and right through his friend's gray
matter they look and find a baseballer
mask that is trying to hunt them down
and this this one is much stronger than
the others these two realize that
there's no Escape enrica analyzes the
situation suggesting that this masked
baseballer might be playing and shooting
in the same interval as someone actually
playing the sport he tells his small
Buddy The Masks might carry on the same
characteristics from their previous life
and this would explain the slight
differences in all the masks they've
seen so far okay this is a sticky
situation we're in a narrow hallway with
a deceivingly strong baseballer who can
throw his cannonballs at the speed of a
Major League baseball player that's not
good I mean look at this guy this is
extremely weird and scary we need to
think fast or we're going to be dead in
no time looking around the place there's
two options we can take and one might
not be as easy as the other our buddy
here might have accidentally nearly died
by a way of a thousand foot drop and we
saved him but this is a piece of
information that we can use to our
advantage our only objective is to live
and get away from the mask killer and we
can do just that if we observe the
building considering that there's an
emergency exit on each floor we can
clearly see that there are many possible
Ledges for us to creep out of the build
now it might be insanely scary and
totally death defying to try climbing up
and down the building like Peter domker
because we actually don't need to pull
off a stun that insane in order to beat
this masked killer if both Rika and his
buddy made the clutch decision to hang
off of the fire exit ledge they can wait
until the baseball mask guy loses sight
of them and either turns around or goes
down another hallway then they can climb
up from the ledge and surprise him from
behind now this is something else that
is easier said than done I know but it's
life or death and we have to take a
chance since Rika here was smart enough
to figure out that masks share the same
characteristics and mannerisms as their
professions from The Real World we can
assume that the baseball mask has a
strong amount of explosive power the
opposite being static strength like the
type scene in bodybuilders this actually
doesn't benefit us since the best option
would be to sneak from behind and
strangle him based on the mask's build
and how he threw the ball his position
would be a pitcher which means that it's
very likely that he can not only throw
fast but he can also throw different
kinds of pitches such as a curveball or
a slider and it also means that up to a
certain distance he's extremely accurate
while it might seem like a better idea
to avoid the killer altogether taking
this guy out means that we have one less
problem to worry about they confront the
pitcher with a large hammer and Rika
just narrowly avoids a deadly pitch he
signals his buddy to shoot the lights
out and smashes the Man's mask off
freaking out rika's buddy shoots the guy
right in his head the next day nisei
picks up a call to find out that it's
her old friend Rika he apologizes to the
girl for what happened to the past and
tells her to take care of his sister
later she admires the view from this
high-rise but is caught by a masked Chef
he pulls a girl down into the building
and introduces himself but this mask is
one they haven't seen before the man
mentions that he's not like the other
masks he's managed to keep his free will
the chef then kicks over a bag of
decapitated heads and walks towards the
girl putting a saw to her neck as she
prepares to die right here but suddenly
she's saved by Yuri who shoots the man
and throws her over a gun suddenly the
man gets back up again and starts pacing
towards her that's when nisei slashes
him to bits tearing the man's head right
right off of his body outside they find
a mysterious group that's looking for
more teammates okay now this is more of
a Bodacious booby trap if I've ever seen
one while making more friends in this
alternate reality is a great idea
believing a cryptic message asking to
meet up is not going to go over well
with me we have to remember that our
objective is to find a helicopter get on
it and get the hell out of here if we
somehow manage to have a dozen people in
our group we'll spend the next year
fighting over whose turn it is for the
helicopter either way we shouldn't have
been taking this note as legitimate
we've just found out that these masked
Killers can keep their Free Will meaning
that this could be written by a masked
individual as well luring innocent
people to their location and killing
them not only that the message was found
right next to where we killed the masked
Chef how would someone be able to write
that message down with a masked killer
on his tail something is fishy and
they're about to find out why the girls
decide to meet up at a location listed
and see what it's about following the
way marked they end up finding
themselves in front of a masked man his
Lackey subdue the girls and the man
takes off his mask saying that he has a
special type of jackpot mask if this
type of mask is found they can end the
world they've been put in he whips off
the tape and reveals that he has one
right here but that's when this Rider
mask interrupts them and begins killing
all of his lackeys he stands in front of
Yuri and the girl gets ready for her
final stand but in a Twist nisei puts on
the jackpot mask she begins laughing
like a maniac and jumps towards the man
slicing his arm clean off the man
punches and breaks her mask she jumps
back and tells Yuri that it's all a part
of her plan she puts on the mask knowing
that some can retain their free will the
masked rider attacks and Yuri notices
that her reflexes have increased heavily
she grabs the man's leg and nisei takes
the killing blow this grizzly traveler
sachio tells them that he's arrived to
kill any of God's candidates the man
questions if they're masks asking to
lend them his power he used to have a
tight group of teammates but they were
ambushed and killed by a god candidate
someone whose aim is to stop people from
ending this reality they've been put in
the girls agree to help him in order to
find new Intel they confront the surgeon
who tells him that he hasn't gathered
enough allies that's when he reveals
that he brought a guard candidate and a
maskless mask user he's getting revenge
for his family and that's that the
surgeon sticks his mask assistant at the
group she remembers that Yuri told her
to Tire them out first and manages to
fight her off that's when sachio rushes
towards the girl and gets a sword to the
chest the two girls continue fighting
but another mask blindsides the group
Yuri shoots him down and the surgeon's
plan of living in this world has failed
the man begins to go crazy giving the
girls no option but to kill him suddenly
the giant Tower explodes in a cloud of
smoke Yuri decides to take this
opportunity and Bluff the surgeon into
thinking that it was her doing his
assistant tries to protect him
submitting to the girl's lies Yuri asks
the man to help sachio with his wounds
and team up for the time being meanwhile
this Samurai masked man is confronted by
Rika and his buddy the killer hands over
a cell phone to the boy hearing the
voice of another student Rika questions
how he got these powers and the kid
explains that he put on a mouthless mask
which gave a collection of powerful
abilities it broke off and now he's a
god candidate the lucky person to become
God will have of all their wishes come
true well that's not so bad now this
changes everything we know what the
point of this reality is and there are
now two options for escape we can either
find a helicopter and leave the
high-rise reality or risk it all and try
our luck at becoming a god candidate if
I were Rika I could gather my group of
lackeys and far away to one of the
helipads and then ditch them as soon as
the helicopter arrives and leaving them
for dead but just this one time I to
take the ultimate risk and aim to be the
soul God candidate not just because we
want to save our friends but because it
seems like the easier option luck is on
our side since our sister will stay with
us no matter what we essentially have
two groups of slight badasses to help
our cause looking at the others group
we've faced so far it doesn't seem like
anyone can match up to our numbers not
only that having multiple God candidates
with mask-like abilities teaming up is a
Surefire way of beating this high-rise
death game and me becoming a god Yuri's
group leaves sanchio under the surgeon's
care telling them not to make any
mistakes or suffer from God's Wrath the
girls continue on the high rise when
suddenly nisei begins to feel a strange
disturbance she's losing her own
willpower and is slowly becoming a
full-blown mask killer they arrive at a
library and get confronted by another
baseball-wielding mask nisei tries to
attack him but she's made quick work up
that's when sniper mask shows himself
for the second time Yuri begins firing
shots and the girls run off they end up
in another building when Nisa here drops
to the floor another mask's killer tries
to Ambush them but the schoolgirl shoots
him with ease nisei reveals that the
mask she used was defective giving her a
short amount of time until she drops
dead the girl decides to leave her but
Yuri tries to hold her back suddenly
nisei turns and starts to spout out
computer commands she ends the computer
sequence in hibernation mode and that's
when this mask casino dealer interrupts
the drama Yuri begs her to explain
what's going on and she reveals that the
mask isn't working on the girl however
it will kill her in around 2 hours if
they don't do anything the only thing
that can save her is a god Canon she
tells them that there is a mouthless
mask around their location and Yuri goes
off to become a God in order to save her
friend okay this is a very honorable
thing for Yuri to do here saving a
friend that's helped her countless times
is definitely something a normal and
good human being would do in a normal
situation however this is not a normal
situation now is it folks and Yuri here
shouldn't consider her a normal person
either now this is the perfect time to
ditch our friend remember the number one
rule and how to beat whenever you get
the chance to ditch your friends take it
in fact we don't need to do anything at
all nisei is suffering from some unknown
mental illness and I personally have no
idea what's going on if I was some
teenage High School student I would
probably just cry in the corner like a
little girl and hope I wake up back in
history class so I know that's probably
not going to be the case Yuri finds
herself stuck under the foot of another
masked man holding a syringe with an
unknown chemical inside the girl manages
to escape and finds the box with her
mouthless mask inside Yuri puts it on
and drops into you to like space and she
wakes back up to see that the man is
moving in slow motion she easily throws
the man off and realizes that she's been
given some insane Powers she's then sent
back into the virtual space and is
confronted by this talking computer
program it explains that her mind and
Consciousness won't be affected by the
mask her new abilities are currently
being installed and she'll need to
figure them out on her own however
she'll need more power if nisei is going
to be safe back in the real world she
receives a call from none other thanise
herself the girl tells her that another
God candidate came to rescue her asking
her to come back hearing this she looks
over the high rise to see which building
her brother's headed to she finds the
building and Promises herself that
they'll reunite meanwhile Rika and this
group here makes it to the building in
the Horizon in order to meet with the
other students suddenly tear gas is
thrown at them and they've fallen into a
trap a mask tries to attack them but
Rika protects his teammates he urges
everyone to run out of the smoke while
he fights the man off he attacks the
masked man getting himself into a sticky
situation that's when this mask's
Aristocrat brutally kills the man and
saves his life all of a sudden three
more enemies show up to their location
Rika begins feeling dizzy from the lack
of blood and passes out the group
continues fighting off these guys
becoming quickly overwhelmed by this
absolute giant who grabs Rika and runs
off with him okay that was pretty
expected come on now how many times do
people have to be ambushed and kidnapped
before we realize that not old people
can be trusted in this world this
student that we've been set up to meet
with doesn't seem like the evil type but
once again we can't judge a book by its
cover however the evil student might not
have been the culprit and maybe this is
just a random Ambush unrelated to the
kid either way with group as big as
rikus they should be constantly on the
lookout in all directions looking for
anything out of the ordinary having a
large group does have both its
advantages and disadvantages there's
power in numbers but arguments can break
out amongst the group and cause problems
to arise when they're in a combat
situation problems that which could turn
out fatal but back to the situation at
hand Rika here put his group in a
terrible situation and could have
avoided being kidnapped with some
unbelievably quick thinking our group is
big enough to take them head off but
we're at a disadvantage because of the
smoke if I was Rika I would simply run
of the smoke and put my own life at
danger for once in my life and scream
out to the rest of my group so they can
back me up the master Killers will
hopefully be distracted by my Macho
screaming and flip the element of
surprise back onto them Yuri finds out
that her brother has been kidnapped she
freaks out and decides to chase him down
she runs into nisei who's in the middle
of a dangerous situation Yuri promises
to kill the enemies for her when
suddenly a bunch of grenades come
launching their way she shoots them all
instantly and everyone realizes that
she's become something truly freaking
awesome a god candidate sniper mask
takes care of the enemies and Nissa here
explains that he's part of the team now
Yuri admits that she's put on a mask and
has gained new powers this blue-haired
girl kuon interrupts their moment to in
herself she shakes hands with Yuri
causing an electric spark to show up the
blue-haired girl realizes that she's
also a god candidate and sends her a
message from sniper mask leave the area
and keep away from him in case he
accidentally attacks meanwhile Rika is
then taken to a mysterious building
where this God candidate akawa has
summoned him the man informs him that he
wants to bring peace and create a
perfect Society he wants Rika to
cooperate and use the people that he's
gathered around him to help him achieve
this and the brother under duress
decides to go along with his demands for
the time being the man compliments Rika
on his will to succeed ordering his
assistant to hold him up ikawa reveals
that he can hold up to 30 masks with his
abilities upstairs he continues to
explain that this world has no God and
that is why they need to hold a
competition in order to Crown one he
takes the kid upstairs showing him this
massive Tower aikawa explains that the
only way to enter is by taking the
helicopter he says that all these other
danger elements of the high-rise world
our tests to say who can handle the
position of God and he's just about past
all of them however a helicopter is
coming their way but they're not
stopping to pick them up ikawa tells
them that these are Guardian Angels a
specific enemy which is their final
obstacle to becoming God that's when the
man leaves Rika in his assistant's care
meanwhile sniper Massacre walks on his
own trying to remember who he was before
entering this world that's when he
realizes that him and Rika used to be
friends but that's when he's spotted by
the enemy sniper mask tries to fire back
but misses and realizes that the enemies
just like him truly horrifying he
realizes that her position will cause
the wind to throw her shot off suddenly
a bullet hits the Rope bridge and sends
it falling with the man hanging for dear
life he accepts his fate telling his
enemy exactly where to shoot him
suddenly the surgeon's assistant
interrupts and saves his life sniper
mask spots the enemy running away but
decides to leave her B okay this whole
situation could have been avoided
entirely if sniper mask was a little
more aware of his environment how could
you not realize that standing on a
bridge tied with a rope would be a bad
idea when trying to get into a firefight
the Mana counted for the fact that the
wind would be at his enemy's
disadvantage but he didn't figure out
that the platform he was standing on
isn't suitable for a counter-attack as
well come on analyzing further the
riggity wooden bridge would have added
another element of difficulty to his
situation there was almost no way for
him to win in this position and taking
cover should have been his first
priority now this might sound like a
stretch but ammunition is limited and if
I was sniper mask here I would want to
avoid having to use any excessive amount
of ammo in a situation that didn't
require it what we can do is simply Run
for Cover and height the enemy is on a
tall building with a view of the entire
city but what she might not realize is
that this is to her disadvantage
eventually someone other than sniper
mask here is going to spot her and
she'll be forced to either Retreat or
fight back in the case of her fighting
back we can use this opportunity to
Blindside her and deliver a killing blow
Sometimes the best things in life take a
bit of patience meane while Yuri and the
others enter this random building nisei
takes their new teammate into the toilet
while Yuri Waits outside nisei confronts
her about the tower inside finding out
that she's the one controlling it she
explains that the railgun is needed to
become God but enemy masks are trying to
stop them from getting it they walk
outside and see Yuri being thrown into
the air turning the corner they found a
strong masked killer waiting for them
the girls mercifully kill him when
suddenly sniper mask reappears Yuri runs
off in fear and the Man Hands over a
phone from the enemy later the surgeon
and his group make it to their location
he introduces this young boy and tells
her to make him feel welcome meanwhile
Rika here has been taken hostage and is
interrogated by this purple-haired lady
she picks up the phone and the boy
overhears that they've had trouble with
a sniper wearing black that's when she
grabs his hand and throws him to the
ground she demands Rika reveal what he
knows but the boy is a freak and hits
his face on the ground before explaining
that sniper mask is an extremely
dangerous mess and he passes out from
the blood loss the surgeon explains that
evil force is out there killing God
candidates one by one he requests Yuri's
help and she agrees to cooperate joining
forces to defeat a common enemy nisei is
given an urgent call and tells the
surgeon to stay put they arrive outside
of his room where his assistant tells
Yuri to pay him a visit by herself she
walks in apologizing for their
differences that's when she hands over a
photo from his brother and reveals what
he's remembered he invites the girl
inside taking off the mask and showing
his handsome stud face the other girl
switched spots with Yuri connecting
hands as they suddenly get sent off into
his memories meanwhile Yuri speaks with
a surgeon's group where she's been given
a brand new piece by the grisly traveler
sachio the girls hear a scream coming
from the other building running across
the Rope Bridge she walks into this dark
room but isn't prepared for what she
sees this girl's dismembered head she's
too late and now these people want her
dead as well the men attack her on site
while Yuri here takes each one out with
ease however she doesn't realize a
stronger mask is watching her from
behind Yuri drops to the ground after
her Ambush and the investigator mask
realizes that this is his opportunity he
Paces in the room and prepares to kill
this girl right here and now he chases
Yuri around the room while preaching his
master akawa's dreams for the world
cornering Yuri he gets ready to brutally
kill her but nisei suddenly appears and
stops the mask from attacking any
further they hold him down and try to
gather some Intel from the man however
all he reveals is that his master ikawa
will soon be the strongest man in the
world later they receive a message from
someone showing the building that Yuri's
brother is in that's when the surgeon
walks by and informs them that he wasn't
able to get any intel from the student
mask however he was able to acquire a
new ability which allows him to stop a
mask's movement sniper mask volunteers
to test it out and the surgeon points
his finger to the man he admits that it
didn't work as intended but it was able
to stop his movement for a split second
upstairs they spot the purple Heritage
lady on this roof a cloud of smoke
appears and Yuri's group shows up to
confront them suddenly the skinny
looking enemy mask gains about 50 pounds
of muscle Ronnie Coleman's style cause
holy smokes and turns into angel mask
their deadliest opponent they have yet
to ever face okay this is some steroid
Insanity right now this master killer
just turned into a roided up freak and
he's about to kill us all great however
we might be able to stop him by using
our brains to overcome his uh physical
advantages judging from The Masks we've
faced previously there's a similar
pattern which emerges from their names
the name or appearances of our enemies
usually give us a clue as how we can
beat them the baseball mask mimicked the
same movements as if he's following the
schedule of someone in the real world
looking at the angel mask based on
physical features alone there isn't much
we can do to beat it however there might
be some Clues on how to beat him based
on the way he looks elsewhere this
freaking weird masked killer jumps high
and scales the building like Spider-Man
while sniper mask up above shoots down
at him but the creepy mask killer
climbing the wall gets inside he munches
on this delicious food when the
surgeon's assistant comes in wink but
the masked killer is too strong and he
appears from right behind her and breaks
her sword in half and that's when the
surgeon and nisei come in to help and
suddenly this surgeon uses his stopping
ability giving them a second to attack
angered this masked killer flicks a
bullet right at the man and fatally
wounds him the assistant takes him to
cover leaving only nisei to deal with
the large threat the overpowering masked
killer pushes her into a wall but that's
when suddenly sacho interrupts to scold
the mask for what he's done nisei sneaks
out and starts talking with her inner
mask to find out what she can do she's
given the option of improving her
processing power in exchange for the
inner mask in the hallway this masked
killer finds nisei getting powered up
and she instantly attacks and tries to
do her best to do some damage nisei
realizes that the man is injured now and
this is her chance to win she jumps out
of the building and signals to the
others that it's go time the sniper
mask's assistant activates her ability
and the railgun goes off in the
battlefield nisei finds that this masked
killer is still alive however he he's
seriously injured nissa's in shock but
suddenly Yuri here shows up to save the
day she points her gun at the man to
deliver a killing blow but her inner
mask interrupts to mention that she's
now been given the ability to control
masked Killers known as Angels like this
Mast killer however it will seal the
man's powers sachio enters the room and
scolds Yuri for beating on the downed
enemy she puts the gun down and decides
to dominate him and strip him of his
powers in the morning the survivors
stand on this high-rise and Yuri here is
more determined than ever to make it
back home but who knows when that's
gonna happen I guess we'll have to find
out in season two and if you don't want
to get your head blown off by a mass
Nipper then like comment let us know
what you like and of course didn't like
and don't forget to check out the harami
playlist down below